Seit dem internationalen astronauten progress in adelaide überschlagen sich die nachrichten in sachen
mond-mission erst war nur von einer raumstation die rede
Die um den mond kreisen soll jetzt geht es schon um die besiedlung und die pläne für die raumstation
scheinen sogar konkrete zu sein als bisher angenommen
Was für den mond geplant ist und wie es mit einer möglichen besiedlung aussieht jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Jetzt geht es wirklich schlag auf schlag ein interview der frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung mit dem deutschen astronauten thomas reiter
Zeigt jetzt wie konkret die pläne schon sind fast, im verborgenen
Liefen die vorbereitungen und es geht schon in zwei jahren los den nacharbeiten
die fünf an der internationalen raumstation beteiligten nationen amerika russland europa japan und kanada bereits seit drei jahren
An dem projekt bereits seit 2012 entwickelt die esa zwei service module für das raumschiff orion mit dem die raumstation
Deep space gateway versorgt werden sollen und auch weitere elemente für die raumstation selbst sind wohl schon in der entwicklung
2009 10 soll bereits der erste flug in eine mondumlaufbahn
stattfinden und bereits
2022 soll mit dem bau der stationen begonnen werden das wäre zwei jahre früher als bisher vermutet es scheint
Dass das jetzt durch die zusage russlands möglich geworden ist die sich bisher noch nicht, so konkret dazu
Geäußert hatten erst auf dem astronauten kongress in adelaide hatte der roskosmos chef igor komarow auf die beteiligung an der raumstation
Verkündet laut reiter ist man jetzt froh bei dem bau der raumstation auf die expertise der russen zurückgreifen zu können insbesondere
Da die mondstation statt 400 kilometern
400.000 kilometer von der erde entfernt ist die europäische, weltraumagentur
esa will für die mondstation übrigens ein ionen triebwerk mit 20 kilowatt leistung bauen und ein modul mit
kommunikations terminal
treibstofftanks einer luftschleuse für wissenschaftliche nutzlasten und einem neuartigen
Adapter an den raumschiffe andocken können und auch eine mondbasis kommt jetzt wieder laut reiter ins gespräch sie
passe perfekt zu einer raumstation
Im mond orbe zitat die vision eines permanent bewohnten mond dorfes wie sieht der esa generaldirektor
Jan wörner vor zwei jahren publik gemacht hat ist bei unseren internationalen partnern auf großes interesse gestoßen
einschließlich russland man könnte vom deep space gateway
Aus sowohl die besiedlung des erdtrabanten
Vornehmen als auch zum mars aufbrechen da sind zum einen sehr spannende
perspektiven und zum anderen soll es jetzt wohl viel schneller gehen als gedacht ich bin extrem gespannt
Wenn es auch sein und kein video dazu verpassen wollen und auch
Zu allen anderen themen da sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen ich den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit mond raumstation konkrete
Pläne da gibt es weitere details zur mondstation deep space geld wäre also nicht verpassen und draufklicken viel spaß haben und ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran